- Des millions de voix s'élèvent
- Alors que le mot-clic
#MoiAussi se répand comme
une trainée de poudre...
- Les témoignages qui se
par dizaine de milliers.
- Octobre 2017.
Le Québec est lui aussi frappé
de plein fouet par la vague
travers le monde. Des voix de
milliers de femmesnt.
En utilisant le mot-clic
#MoiAussi, elles détaillent
les inconduites sexuelles
qu'elles ont subi.
- Il était temps que ça
se dénonce puis qu'il y ait
quelque chose qui soit mis
à l'avant-plan.
- Ça a ouvert la conversation.
- J'ai l'impression que
ça a libéré la parole
et que ça a été positif
dans ce sens-là.
- Cinq ans plus tard,
le mouvement est encore présent
dans la mémoire collective,
et ses impacts au sein
de la société se font sentir.
RACHEL CHAGNON, professeure,
Départ. Sc. juridiques, UQAM
- #MeToo a été finalement une
vague qui a frappée suffisamment
fort pour ouvrir la boîte, puis
faire en sorte qu'il y comme
un consensus social qui a bougé,
par rapport, justement, au fait
que les crimes à caractère
sexuel, la violence sexuelle,
c'est une vraie violence
sexuelle, puis quel les victimes
de ce type de crime-là sont
des vraies victimes.
- Un tribunal spécialisé
en matière de violence sexuelle
et conjugale a vu le jour
au Québec. Un projet-pilote
est actuellement à l'essai
dans une dizaine de districts
de la province.
- Il y a eu une prise de
conscience. Il y a des efforts
qui sont faits pour prouver
que le système de justice
peut répondre adéquatement
aux besoctimes.
- La réflexion est bien entamée,
mais sur le terrain,
les intervenants remarquent
qu'il y a encore beaucoup
il à faire.
JUSTINE CHÉNIER, responsable des
communications RQCALACS
- Les changements sont à
géométrie variable.- C'est pourn
d'une loi-cadre dans les écoles
primaires et secondaires
de la province pour prévenir
les violences sexuelles
est réclamée.
- La lutte contre les violences
sexuelles n'est pas terminée.
- Je pense que socialement,
il faut qu'on poursuive
cette réflexion collective là et
qu'on n'ait pas cette tentation
de se réfugier derrièr
le tribunal pour dire que
les problèmes sont réglés.
- Et tout ne se règle pas par le
biais des tribunaux criminels.
D'autres actions, comme
la poursuite du dialogue et
une meilleure éducation, peuvent
être prises collectivement.
Un long travail, qui nécessite
la collaboration de tous et
chacun.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Mon